these woods on the highway to Minsk were
the site of a mass murder and right next
to the improvised memorial is a
restaurant by a gym by a team let's go
and eat is just a short drive away for
the residents of the Belarusian capital
zhenya Sorbonne Norwich thinks it's
horrible that people dine here the 29
year old is handing out flyers to the
guests he wants to ensure the atrocities
committed here are not forgotten and
that the restaurant is closed some of
the visitors are aware of where they're
going and some aren't and some people
don't mind eating on bones xeni stands
vigil outside the restaurant every
weekend he's a critic of the government
and sees himself as an opposition
activist he's the chairman of the young
front a nationalistic youth movement
pushing for Democratic Change the
activists call this the restaurant of
death and they stand outside it in
shifts the owner of the restaurant
doesn't want to speak to us and were not
allowed to film beyond the driveway the
activists say when the restaurant
complex was built the official border of
the mass grave was shifted but
ultimately no one knows where the
memorial should begin or end Joseph
Stalin had between 30,000 and 250,000
people shot here in the late 30s and
early 40s declared enemies of the state
those murdered were innocent victims of
the Soviet dictators purges it was
shortly before the end of the Soviet
Union that the knowledge of this site
became public since then it has become
an impromptu people's memorial and a
centre of opposition activity zhenya
Sorbonne Norwich came here the first
time when he was 15 with his father
usually it smells like pine needles and
leaves in the woods but here you have
the feeling that thousands of candles
are burning denise's great-granduncle is
one of the victims buried here he was a
teacher
Denis has sworn to defend the memorial I
just can't give this place off I don't
know how I could ever close my eyes -
cooter party I won't be able to sleep at
night if I do when I come here something
shifts in me I start thinking
differently a half a year ago the
Belarusian government set up an official
monument to the victims of Stalin's
secret police at the edge of the forest
the government removed dozens of large
crosses and built a fence around the
whole area officials said the crosses
had been put up illegally for zinnias
the move was yet another warning signal
he's concerned the government wants to
take control of the memorial and points
out the country's president Alexander
Lukashenko has often praised Stalin's
legacy we have to have a plan on how to
finish fixing up kora potty but no one
should be able to do anything here
without permission what's going on here
are demonstrations it must be in
someone's interest these are political
protests Lukashenko has also said that
the restaurant by the mass grave doesn't
bother him but in Minsk not everyone
agrees it depends where the restaurant
is it's not in the middle of the crosses
is it it's somewhere on the edge near
the exit I think that's fine in Minsk
everything is right and proper motion
there are bones everywhere in Belarus we
don't know everything that happened here
but life has to go on so now people go
to a spot where people were killed to
have a good time it's not right
Zenoss agrees he makes the bus journey
from Minsk to Kiribati at least twice a
week he has been protesting against the
restaurant here for a year and
demonstrators want to keep fighting
Zenoss and the others see this
restaurant as an attack on the memorial
and for them that means it's an attack
on the people of Belarus we don't really
have anything of our own anymore
but we do have kuta party in the US they
are here and we have to defend them if
the government destroy SCOOTER party I
won't call myself a Belarusian anymore
they sing for Belarus and for the
victims here in the woods it's a prayer
for the dead but zhenya sorbonne ovitch
has demands for the living as well he
wants the whole historical truth of this
place to be revealed and is demanding
the opening of Soviet archives